i cambiamenti climatici
sappiamo tutti che sono un tema molto
controverso
oggi nonostante la comunità scientifica
a disposizione una quantità di dati
molto numerosi
nonostante sebbene la scienza
attribuisca allo sviluppo industriale
un'importante responsabilità non sia una
vera e propria risposta definitiva a
questa problematica
e infatti dobbiamo tenere conto che oggi
lo sviluppo industriale incide molto sui
fenomeni naturali accelerando lì per la
prima volta nella storia la terra deve
fare i conti anche con una specie così
distribuita nel mondo è così
industrializzata impattante e così
numerosa soprattutto non ci
dimentichiamo che oggi siamo più di 7
miliardi di persone negli ultimi 15 anni
della mia vita grazie al mio lavoro ho
avuto l'opportunità di viaggiare molto
in zone particolarmente remote e
affascinanti della terra è solo un
fotografo naturalista specializzato nel
settore della montagna e del paesaggio e
grazie alle mie immagini cerco di
stimolare la curiosità tra l'interazione
sull'interazione tra uomo e natura e su
quello che comporta questa interazione
quasi dieci anni fa ho iniziato a
pensare ad un progetto che mi desse la
possibilità tramite la fotografia
di contribuire a quello che è la
comprensione degli effetti dei
cambiamenti climatici
e infatti la fotografia da quando esiste
circa il 1850 e sempre stato uno
strumento della ricerca scientifica e
sono state proprio queste le motivazioni
che mi hanno spinto a realizzare il
progetto sulle tracce dei ghiacciai
il progetto sulle tracce dei ghiacciai e
è un progetto fotografico scientifico
che contribuisce nella ricerca
scientifica e prevede e prevede diverse
spedizioni sul campo nelle catene
montuose più importanti del pianeta si
sviluppa nell'arco di circa 10 anni e
durante queste spedizioni andiamo a
realizzare diversi diverse fotografie le
stesse fotografie scattate tra fine
ottocento e primi del novecento dagli
stessi esploratori dagli dagli
esploratori fotografi che hanno visitato
quelle regioni e grazie a questi
confronti realizziamo riusciamo a capire
quelli che sono state le modificazioni
del paesaggio in queste regioni
oltretutto durante queste spedizioni
coinvolgiamo anche dei ricercatori
glaciology che vengono con noi e
realizzano prendono dei dati concreti
delle misurazioni glaciologiche e grazie
a questo lavoro ci stiamo cercando
stiamo contribuendo alla ricerca
scientifica e dalla comprensione degli
effetti dei cambiamenti climatici in
relazione al fenomeno dell'arretramento
degli acciai
oltretutto questo progetto ci dà la
possibilità di sviluppare di parlare di
sé i valori che personalmente reputo
molto importanti come lo sviluppo
sostenibile il la salvaguardia di un
patrimonio storico culturale che abbiamo
in italia ma nel mondo come gli archivi
fotografici e tanti altri valori come il
risparmio energetico
l'importanza della ricerca scientifica
che purtroppo in particolare in italia
non viene sponsorizzata dalle
istituzioni
inoltre queste spedizioni hanno una
metodologia particolare a ogni siano
stati già in karakorum in pakistan
vicino alla seconda montagna più alta
del mondo caucaso in alaska
durante queste spese prima di queste
spedizioni quasi un anno prima
andiamo a realizzare un vero e proprio
una ricerca d'archivio delle fotografie
che hanno devono avere prettamente due
interessi l'interesse scientifico
l'interesse fotografico la particolarità
di essere molto particolarmente
estetiche
inoltre cerchiamo di pianificare tutte
quelle problematiche
ecco queste sono alcune immagini di
confronto che vedremo poi in seguito
lo studio anche delle mappe topografiche
storiche che ci aiutano a posizionare le
immagini nei luoghi abbiamo anche
andiamo a studiare tutti i libri
fotografici ai laghi e le diari di
viaggio dei fotografi per capire
esattamente da dove hanno scattato
queste immagini
inoltre cerchiamo di pianificare anche
tutte le problematiche logistiche legate
all approvvigionamento di cibo siamo
costretti a restare nella natura
incontaminata per un mese e mezzo quindi
approvvigionamento di cibo acqua
spostamenti guide alpine portatori e
annullamento di animali che ci aiutano a
portare il materiale viaggiamo con 4 5
600 chili di materiale il problema
dell'ipossia quindi la mancanza di
ossigeno in karakorum
abbiamo lavorato dai 4.000 e 6.000 metri
e tutti voi sapete che in altissima
quota si ragiona in maniera molto più
lenta si fatica molto di più quindi sono
tutte problematiche che vanno
considerate per riuscire a raggiungere i
luoghi fotografici le stazioni
fotografiche
inoltre dobbiamo anche durante le
spedizioni georeferenziato tutte le
immagini e questo per dare la
possibilità a futuri fotografi futuri
scienziati di rifare lo stesso nostro
lavoro con maggiore facilità e fine
spedizione seguito ritornando in italia
andiamo a realizzare un vero e proprio
lavoro di restauro delle fotografie
storiche e di post produzione delle
immagini moderne
è un lunghissimo lavoro che dura diversi
mesi e infine per divulgare al pubblico
il risultato di questi di questo lavoro
realizziamo delle esposizioni la mostra
fotografica itinerante dei documentari
televisivi dei progetti didattici sia
nei luoghi che abbiamo visitato sia in
italia con le scuole e ovviamente la
presenza anche sui media
produciamo una rassegna stampa di circa
400 pagine l'anno
qui siamo in karakorum possiamo vedere
come questo ghiacciaio il ghiacciaio
biagio ha avuto in 100 anni un
arretramento di circa 3 chilometri è
sparito completamente il ghiacciaio
questa parte centrale in rilievo e tutto
ghiaccio può sembrare strano ma è nero
perché è coperto da detrito questa è una
delle caratteristiche pure il motivo per
cui questi ghiacciai a volte hanno un
inerzia molto forte sia il cambiamento
climatico all'aumento di temperatura
questo il ghiacciaio baltoro il 4 il
quarto ghiacciaio più grande del mondo
più lungo del mondo quasi 60 km ha perso
soprattutto a differenza dell'altro
ghiacciaio che si trova semplicemente a
300 metri più in basso il suo spessore
quelle lì in basso sono delle tende e
quindi stiamo parlando di uno spessore
di circa 60 70 60 metri questo
addirittura invece è un ghiacciaio che è
in avanzata negli anni cinquanta è
avanzato di circa un chilometro e mezzo
in soli tre mesi anche questo si pensi
si pensa che sia un effetto dei
cambiamenti climatici
qui invece siamo sempre sul baltoro in
mezzo c'è il k2 broad peak le montagne
più alte del mondo il ghiaccio umbro 1
il gasherbrum iv quindi bacini di
accumulo da dove la neve si accumula e
poi si porta con delle grandi valanghe
sui ghiacciai e i cambiamenti non sono
così non sono stati così evidenti a
parte dello spessore
qui invece siamo sempre in karakorum in
caucaso dove invece gli acciai sono in
bassissima quota rispetto al karakorum
che invece arrivano a una quota di circa
3000 metri invece in causa sui ghiacciai
addirittura hanno lasciato spazio alle
intere foreste a distanza di 134 anni
questo ghiacciaio altri bury era uno dei
ghiacciai più grandi del caucaso
maggiore si è arretrato di 5 km queste
stiamo parlando di una valle larga c'è
un chilometro e mezzo e profonda 5
quindi delle masse glaciali enormi qui
siamo a 3000 metri davanti ai colossi
del caucaso maggiore tra russia e
caucaso
il tecnico di un 4900 quindi più alto
del monte bianco lo scarica un 5200
questo ghiacciaio nonostante abbia un
bacino di accumulo molto alto e un
iphone molto ripida di circa 1500 metri
che quindi a porta neve al ghiacciaio si
è arretrato si è ha diminuito il suo
spessore della sua massa di circa 80
metri e si è arretrato di un chilometro
e mezzo
questo è calato invece il cavo del
cervino del caucaso lush vale un 5200
una montagna che appunto porta molto
ghiaccio agli acciai sottostanti e
nonostante questo il ghiacciaio in poco
più di cento anni ha lasciato una valle
detritica sotto di sé questa
elaborazione appunto che è stato fatto
da un ricercatore che è venuto con noi
grazie ai dati satellitari i dati delle
mappe urss i dati che abbiamo ripreso
durante la spedizione si può vedere come
le superfici di questi ghiacciai si sono
hanno diminuito appunto la loro
superficie quindi ci siamo in alaska
dove i ghiacciai hanno avuto forse uno
tra i più grossi più forti arretramenti
mai visti nella storia alcuni ghiacciai
hanno perso 60 km in realtà la per la
particolarità di questi ghiacciai e che
non hanno un diretto una diretta
relazione con il cambiamento climatico
infatti vengono i fenomeni che fanno sì
che questi ghiacciai si arrestano sono i
più disparati in particolare tidewater
che un fenomeno proprio che disgrega il
ghiaccio pensate che glacier bay
national park questo pare uno dei parchi
nazionali più grappelli dell'alaska
degli stati uniti ha perso una quantità
di ghiaccio di circa 3.400 54 chilometri
cubi di ghiaccio e questo ha fatto sì
che tutti gli oceani del mondo si sono
alzati di un centimetro
può sembrare poco ma non è assolutamente
poco quindi come avete potuto vedere da
queste immagini qui addirittura si
vedono dei ghiacciai che quasi si
toccavano invece adesso si sono staccati
si sono disgregati di decine e decine di
chilometri quindi ripeto da quello che
abbiamo visto potete forse avete capito
che le dinamiche degli acciai sono molto
variegate e le motivazioni che mi hanno
spinto a portare a cercare di realizzare
una documentazione più oggettiva
possibile sono è proprio il fatto che
hanno una dinamica molto complessa e
soprattutto differente fra di loro e per
me è stato importante è importante
riuscire a consegnare al comitato
glaciologico al comitato scientifico che
abbiamo costituito appositamente per
questo progetto consegnare loro una
documentazione più variegata possibile
proprio perché le dinamiche di ghiacciai
sono molto variegate inoltre non volevo
essere additato come il classico
fotografo ecologista che va in giro per
il mondo a fotografare i ghiacciai per
dare esclusivamente colpa
all'industrializzazione dell'uomo
siamo stati quindi come dicevo prima in
karakorum in caucaso in alaska nel 2016
andremo in patagonia argentina e cilena
in seguito in himalaya
in particolare in nepal in sikkim e in
tibet e e poi per finire il progetto
andremo a visitare le nostre alpi franco
svizzero italiane quello che avete visto
questa sera forse vi sembrerà forse
lontano dalle nostre vite quotidiane
in realtà in questi ultimi 30 anni
stiamo osservando una estremizzazione
dei fenomeni naturali e una vera e
propria accelerazione dei fenomeni
naturali a cui l'uomo ha grosse
difficoltà ad adattarsi
pensate anche a alle grossi alluvioni
anche nel nostro territorio che ha un
sistema un territorio anche molto
complicato con un rischio idrogeologico
molto particolare come come la
tropicalizzazione del mediterraneo
grandi uragani che finora li vedevamo
lontani negli stati uniti invece stanno
arrivando anche in europa
queste estremizzazione dei fenomeni
naturali quindi va mitigata ovviamente
per mitigare questi di questi questi
questi fenomeni
bisogna capirli studiarli e quindi credo
che sia fondamentale riuscire ad
aumentare il più possibile la
consapevolezza di ognuno di noi
su queste problematiche e tenendo conto
che ognuno di noi ha una forte
responsabilità quotidiana e quindi
tenere conto a cercare di comprendere
che il preservare l'ambiente vuol dire
anche preservare noi stessi come
individui e come specie grazie a tutti